[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i saw where tim tebow alex smith and
ryan leaf among the first time
candidates for the college football hall
of fame that was announced on monday and
ryan leaf happened to be in town the
espn college football analyst also works
for sirius xm westwood one
sky sports the former nfl quarterback
number two pick overall all right rank
those quarterbacks
tim tebow alex smith ryan leaf in
college tim tebow's probably the
greatest college quarterback ever to
play i think okay i just think he's the
the epitome of a college
superstar quarterback so i think he's
the best that ever play that position
how did he not stay in the nfl
well i think you know you've been around
long enough you've seen situations just
like mine that it depends on where you
go how you deal with it but you had
talent
you don't think he had talent not to
throw the football it was it was
different it was but if you go back to
college he found ways to get it done he
found ways to win a playoff game in the
nfl i mean he he found ways to get it
done you're exactly right he wasn't a
pure passer so
uh you needed somebody to give him a
shot and just teams were not at some
point willing to give him any more shots
and that's that's just the nature of the
business but how do you throw for ten
thousand yards but you can't throw ryan
uh
ah
that's an interesting concept i mean
we've seen a ton of college football
players that have been incredibly good
uh uh that just haven't been able to
develop at the next level they didn't
have the same type of
acumen as they did in college to advance
at the nfl it's just it's just the
nature of the but it's but his throwing
motion is not good it felt like it's
labored it looks labored i think a lot
of lefties
look labored in their throwing if you
look it just i mean even steve young
even though his pure passer he was it
almost kind of looked labored and i
don't know why
but we've i think you and i talked about
this before in terms of left-handed
left-handed quarterbacks and what that
means and in particular a couple years
ago when i was on the show talking about
the the tua burro herbert draft
well you look at kenny stabler you know
the uh left-handed quarter michael vick
could throw a football yeah he didn't
look labored at all no no no no he could
throw but tua
two of labors yeah it it is and and i
always thought that was going to be a
bit of a struggle for him at the next
level but he has got some weapons now
so i mean there's no there's no excuse
when this season's over
if it doesn't work out right i mean two
was you're gonna move off that spot uh
you know and and find a new quarterback
but what would it take for the dolphins
to look at two and go we're gonna we're
gonna keep this together like what
numbers or
progress with the team do you think you
need i think they'd have to win the
division
those are high expectations i believe
they'd have to win the division two to
be in that and they have to go up
against the likes of josh allen yeah i
mean if that's really tight if they're
able to knock off alan and it comes down
to it they get in as a wild card
um and he's improving urine i just don't
know if anybody after what they've gone
through the last two years and kind of
the back stabbing that's gone on i don't
know if anybody has any confidence in
anybody else right now certainly
ownership hasn't shown that yeah
yeah i just wonder with tua
that he does have weapons he got waddle
and now you have tyrique uh yeah
maybe they're so open that he doesn't
have to fit it into those tight windows
he's incredibly accurate though that's
the one thing i took away from what he
did in college his guys were wide open
don't get me wrong but he was accurate
with the football so i still believe
that's still in him at this level
arm strength overrated or underrated in
the nfl
it's overrated
uh
it's special when you have it josh allen
being in particular patrick mahomes but
as you see in other positions other
players i mean tom brady's arm strength
isn't necessarily overpowering in any
way but if you look at that last
touchdown to mike evans in the playoff
game
he didn't hesitate on throwing it's you
know 50 yards down the football field
and hitting him in stride so he still
can get it done for what he needs to and
that is he's a perfect showcase of of
doing it the right way with not the
elite arm that that a lot of people ooh
and ah when they go to the combine how
much do you think today's nfl and the
rules in protecting a quarterback have
played into tom brady's longevity i
think it's been a big part of it it
really has i mean i i look back at bruce
smith and reggie white planting me into
the ground and derek thomas and i'm like
that would never happen these days right
but you've got to give him a ton of
credit and what he's done and how he's
transformed his body in the nutrition
the aspect all those things that he has
done he's put in the work and then the
rules
have compensated
to help bring him along that he can be
45
and play professional football i can't
believe it my last collegiate football
game was against him in the rose bowl
and he couldn't even get on the football
field
yet he's still playing and i like you
know i have to to get up an hour in
advance and do calisthenics today i
would have told you back then you're
playing at washington state you play in
michigan
and you're the star
and if i would have said hey leaf you
know who the best quarterback is in the
rose bowl that guy right over there
who's not even playing me and coach
price uh we have an ongoing joke that we
we always would stand on the field look
at the other quarterbacks warm up
beforehand and i remember telling coach
price at the time
see that guy wearing and he was wearing
number 10. brady you know you know
toothpicks coming out of his shoulder
pads a bike coach that's gonna be the
greatest quarterback to ever play the
game
uh it's interesting that
coach doesn't remember you saying that i
didn't say that of course you did
we had no idea who he was you know we
were focused on charles woodson in that
defense which is rightfully so but brian
griese played a heck of a game that day
it was a wonderful rose bowl but it's
ironic yeah he was he was on the field
uh you know and then everything that
happened um have you have you a chance
to watch the man in the arena yet some
of it yeah i sat down during the
pandemic here and just just devoured it
and it's
from from a guy that wasn't able to
succeed at the thing he's been great at
it's so interesting to watch it
and he's and see him um have success
because there's a lot of the things he
thinks about and does now that i've that
i've put into my life the way i use uh
my new brain chemistry and things like
that so it makes a lot of sense
on how much success he's had
what advice would you give baker
mayfield
uh i i continue to to do what he's doing
right i mean do not do not waver at all
he's the one who has all the leverage
right now they've already said you know
desean watson is the adult in the room
apparently
and so stay strong um you know get your
money and get a chance somewhere else
eventually i don't know how this is
going to play out they have to release
him he can't be on this roster next year
but what if you find out deshawn watson
suspended for the first eight games of
the season or the entire year and you're
baker mayfield
i i i want to play i would think in a
lesson
what would be the best possible scenario
for for baker mayfield to play in an
offense that he knows is kevin stefanski
going to play him
after all that's gone on
of all the
the
the crap he has taken this off season
and dished himself
how is this going to be any bit
non-chaotic it may be less chaotic if uh
baker mayfield's starting than it would
be if deshaun watson's starting but it's
going to be chaos and they're not going
to have a chance i don't think to be
successful if baker mayfield's the
starting quarterback in cleveland the
team that should trade for baker
mayfield
um
i'd like to see him go someplace where
he could he could maybe sit but i do
think carolina is a place that still can
i am a big fan of sam darnold i still am
i still believe he has something in him
i just somebody needs to give him the
right the right opportunity and i'm
hoping that happens in carolina this
year but if it doesn't
um i think that he has a chance to go
there and maybe kind of mitchell
trubisky it uh and i don't think he has
the ego to mitchell true biscuit
i don't think so either
i don't think so either i think it
everybody he's a star in his own mind
and i can and i can relate to that
because when i was in seattle and mike
holmgren
had me with matt hasselbeck and trent
dilfer and asked me to hey
sit
learn
you know be the third string quarterback
my ego
didn't wouldn't allow it i'd always been
the starting quarterback dan so how was
i going to be anything else in my mind i
was just like i'm i'll quit i quit and
that's what i did
so i i get wait you quit instead of
being the third string quarterback yeah
i could have played for i mean look look
at what backup quarterbacks make these
days and play for years right my ego my
pride my pride was so overwhelming and i
was so sick at the time i was so
mentally ill i was so depressed i i
couldn't admit to coach holmgren and say
hey i'm really struggling here can you
help me instead i just said i'm
i'm gone
we're talking to ryan leaf he works for
espn doing college football games also
works for sirius xm westwood 1 sky
sports and of course the former number
two overall pick by the chargers 1998
draft
nil when you were at washington state
how would you have handled money at
washington state
well i it probably would have
exacerbated the character defects that
would come later when money came earlier
and maybe gave me a chance to learn and
but uh
i was talking to a an individual about
my time in college the other day
and i was looking for some negative
things like some red flags some things
that
without hindsight
you know hindsight's easy for people to
go back oh that's that was there wasn't
that people didn't think that i won i
was competitive i think the biggest red
flag and the only one that maybe existed
is i wasn't a captain why isn't the
quarterback who's the leader of this
team supposedly why isn't he the captain
of the football team that may have been
the biggest red flag other than that why
weren't you the captain
um i wasn't well liked you know i i
didn't work as hard in the weight room
and things like that things came easy to
me and i just expected maybe more from
my teammates
than they thought i gave back in return
and so and the two guys that were voted
captains were
were
well liked you know i was named captain
for the rose bowl i think that was more
of a doing for mike price because of
of what we had accomplished and got
there but you know i think that's that's
a that's something that um
that scouts and
um coaches look at now when they're
going through the draft process if
that's the case i always think of draft
day the movie the cleveland browns with
kevin costner and they passed on you
know the quarterback o'callaghan
because he wasn't the team captain and
wanted to know why he wasn't and uh so i
always think about that when i
is that based on you
i i didn't get any royalties from it i
know they i know they say my name and i
know jennifer garner i wonder if
jennifer gardner even knew who i was
when she when she's like when she's made
the confidence i'm going to say no yeah
probably not but she knew tom brady yeah
of course everybody knows tom brady um
maybe it was
who knows i think like i said i didn't
get any but how much does arrogance play
in the role or and maybe arrogance isn't
the right word but like do you need to
be arrogant to a certain degree i think
there's a fine line between what you
call arrogance and maybe just
just you know
total confidence in what you can do like
dan marino to me
had an arrogance to him like he wanted
he he just had that attitude and i did
too elway i did too and for the
when i was successful the difference is
is those individuals who can have that
swagger can have that arrogance and fail
and still find their way through it
when i failed like i blew the whole
thing up
right i was i was going mach 10 you know
i'm with my hair on fire and taking
everybody with me if you if you weren't
with me
and that's the difference and so when
i'm out you know when i'm out speaking
all the time now i talk about that i'm
talking about it's it's not about the
circumstance anymore it's about how you
deal with it period and there are a ton
of individuals i think at the
quarterback position that deal with
failure tremendously better than than
those of us back then me in particular
because that's what i wonder about baker
mayfield is he wired to be a backup is
he can he hit a reset button given that
personality the chip on your shoulder
i mean ryan tannehill did it but ryan
tannehill was wired differently than
baker mayfield jameis winston was able
to sort of rewire himself
marcus mariota didn't have to rewire
himself it's the same kind of
personality there but i mean those are
examples of ones who could and ones who
couldn't incredibly difficult especially
when you're that high of a draft pick
the expectations that come with it yeah
it's going to be hard i think it's gonna
be hard for marcus mariota in atlanta i
think it's gonna be hard
uh you know you know i think jameis
winston was coming along last year
before the injury but i think that's
incredibly difficult unless you're able
to humble yourself if he's able to do
that
which i think a lot of people who know
him or
see him from afar don't believe that's
possible then i would expect the guy to
maybe bounce around and be a journeyman
or maybe even just be out of the nfl
the 49ers situation i'm trying to figure
this out because they're playing a
dangerous game here
i think garoppolo needs to stay and be
the quarterback there i think he's a
good quarterback he's not great he's
good
trey lance i just don't think he's ready
and i don't know why
they went all in on him yeah and when
you go all in we want to see you right
away because it's like we went all in on
you you better
i mean his nickname is one play trey
because he had one play so far in his
nfl career like i'm a little i haven't
heard that one
i'm a little concerned about that i
would be concerned too if you're 49ers
fans out there this guy could could be
the number three overall draft pick and
not playing his first two seasons right
and when they moved heaven and earth to
get it done
i'm with you i'm a big jimmy garoppolo
fan you know i i battle with people who
uh he's a guy that's played in big games
now he hasn't made the big plays in
those moments and that's why the
criticism can stand and can hold because
in the biggest moments of the biggest
games
he hasn't come through it's a big reason
why teams who watched him overthrow that
pass in the super bowl against kansas
city understand what they have to do to
get to the next level at the quarterback
position that's why you see such big
moves to get it done so um i don't think
i think it says speaks volumes and says
a lot more about what trey lance has
been in san francisco than what's going
on with jimmy garoppolo to be honest
when you're matthew stafford
and and you i'm not going to say get out
of jail you get out of detroit and you
get a chance to play with you know some
really talented players there
like i don't know if he he do you try to
do less because you tried to do more in
detroit and and you know that that can
be kind of a dangerous approach to the
game
and i think there were some growing
pains mid-season i called i called the
tennessee
rams game a sunday night football game
after derrick henry had um
got injured and was out and i was
looking all week at how this
titans team was going to be able to slow
down first off matthew stafford in this
offense and then do anything offensively
against that great defense
and you know to your point matthew
stafford tried to do
way too much he tried to be the detroit
version of himself and when talent is
around you you don't you have to just do
what you do naturally and we saw that
come out in the super bowl a couple of
strollers late in the game
that was the just the let it rip let it
go matthew stafford and in that game i
called kevin byrd just
just knew what was going on and he took
advantage of what matthew stafford was
trying to accomplish in terms of being
detroit matthew and they got beat at
home and i was just astonished when i
was
in the booth there that night but that's
what sean mcvay allows for matthew
stafford just to be him and they can win
don't try to be more be who you are the
talent is abundant here in los angeles
aaron donald is always
he's an interesting case study because
you know he went the mid first round
you know you look at his draft profile
six foot tall you know all this stuff
but we
we keep looking for the next mahomes the
next bosa the next the next the
i haven't heard anybody say we're
looking for the next aaron donald
i mean it's it's hard to these diamonds
in the rough
um
are are
there for a reason because they they've
been successful right you don't
i'm the prototic i'm the prototypical
size
arm
strength of a quarterback physicality
wise aaron donald isn't he's not he's
not what you look for and that's not the
number one overall draft picks on the
defensive front right you don't have
these pass rushers the likes of trayvon
walker who went number one this year he
doesn't look like aaron donald he looks
like a beast he looks like michael
strahan right that's what they're
searching for if you were able to find a
guy
like aaron donald by all means but i
don't think they they don't grow on
trees so you don't see them being
plucked because they don't exist
how many hall of famers sacked you
uh
strahan
reggie white derek thomas
um
bruce smith who hit you the hardest ray
lewis uh lacerated my spleen oh
do you know in the moment no i just
thought i thought i cracked a rib and
maybe punctured my lung or something
like that
it was
spitting up blood it was that 2000
ravens team and we lost 24 to 3 in
baltimore
how good was that defense
so good three-step drop
sara goosa those guys were they were in
on me
rod woodson was playing safety at the
time
i mean i got to play against some pretty
good some pretty good teams uh in the
history of football i remember we were
playing carolina and it was when reggie
white was in carolina and i had one of
my better games but i moved around the
pocket one time and got away
and i was being held by my leg by
somebody and i just
reared back and threw one about 60 yards
down the field to jeff grammy makes a
great catch
and all of a sudden i hear this this
voice as he stands up and everybody
knows reggie white's voice
damn leaf you a big boy
i'll always remember that to this day
you know
rest is soul so uh i got to play against
some pretty good ones yeah he might be
their greatest defensive player of all
time
he may be and that was at the end of his
career yeah you know julius peppers
probably sits in that position luke k
lukickley you could probably say just
the the impact but yeah i mean
he was a
he was a difference maker he changed the
way that position was played yeah i mean
we think of lawrence taylor there's a
couple of guys you think of with the
modern modern day football modern day
nfl
but
aaron donald's in that conversation
you know is he better than j.j watt
career-wise
oh yeah he's won a championship
okay but
that that that's the measuring stick for
me in a lot of ways um and i think it is
for a lot of we avoided injuries too
because yeah
jj hasn't but i mean
how many defensive player of the year
award says is donald went to i think uh
two and jj's got three yeah so i mean
you could you know apples and oranges
there i just
um in his prime jj watt and his ability
his athletic ability to get up and knock
balls down and intercept the football
and things like that i mean they made
different impacts
but you could compare them okay but at
their peak
um
aaron donald just he's a guy that that
aaron donald has three yes three yeah
okay they're the same they both have
there yeah i i would say aaron donald in
his prime just
just the the the way he effect
effectively changes the game jj did that
don't get me wrong but they were able to
neutralize them from time to time it's
been hard for teams to figure that out
against aaron donald and gotta give
raheem morris a ton of credit because he
was being neutralized in the first half
of that super bowl they found a way to
get one-on-one match-ups in the second
half to set him free and let him lose
it's great to see you too yeah i'm glad
my family got to see him macgyver i
think last time
was like one years old yeah you really
did name your son macgyver
it
it fits him to a t i remember when he
said that paulie goes you'll never guess
leaf named his kid i go uh ryan he goes
no macgyver i go no he didn't he goes no
he named him macgyver yeah
was it your idea
this is a funny story um
my parents were in town and they were
they came over and they said
let's let's put a list together of names
so
anna my wife was
you know throwing some names against the
wall and one of the names she threw was
just macgyver
mom chuckled a little bit and i had a
little laugh
uh and then when we got the list that
night nana and i were looking at it
like i go
she didn't put macgyver down
and uh i looked over at and she goes oh
macgyver is his name
oh so it's kind of a spiteful name at
first and now it's become like this
amazing macgyver and my mom's the first
to say it's he it's exactly everybody
loves it it fits him perfectly he uh a
lot of nicknames with it he's gonna be a
giant he's gonna be like six foot nine i
think so
proud of him macgyver macgyver great to
see you buddy thanks for stopping by
it's ryan leaf espn college football
analyst and uh nominee for the college
football hall of fame we'll take a break
phone is coming up adam sandler in a
little bit dan patrick's show so dan
we're gonna play a little game without
looking can you tell who's throwing the
ball just close your eyes
you're gonna look this way so you're
gonna stand over here and so one of us
will throw and then the other one will
throw and just
see you want to be the the guy be the
guy he's not going to throw i'll be here
he's going to catch well i mean
everybody knows this cannon's going to
win you're right
okay all right here is the first guy
i felt like it was ryan i think i hurt
my shoulder on that one
i think i heard i told you what are you
doing i told you this camp fire are you
all right pretty you want to
who go up that way by not warming up
that was my warm-up i see brady's
already got up here at the new unity
uniform yeah it's just a big round
big round
oh yeah all right ask it let me let
go ahead todd let me see
okay
speaking of left handers don't wait
touch
todd you look labored
[Laughter]
here we go
am i throwing it to you or just throwing
to the wall
throat
see this is where
okay
pretty close very close all right she's
close barney trying to slide them off
here we go
here we go
oh we got another lefty here five
minutes
all right there's a little fella upset
right over there he can sling it a
little bit
mario oh mario come here
blame that on seat now yeah wrong rap
you gotta lay out
around stop doing it
if you care
right here
i like 1000
birds you got a new contract yeah
renfro
oh yeah you've got a two-year deal i was
down there speaking at clemson a couple
years ago and you just got sitting in
the front row and it just it looks like
an insurance salesman that just like
came into like yeah he's going bald
got a hundred catches last year yeah
maybe one of the best what slot
receivers he's good all right he's good
clear